[Music]
don't go anywhere being in a bald eagle
nest is surreal
this is a wild animal she's being rowdy
it's very capable of hurting you if
you're not careful so you have to take
your time a little rough huh sorry about
that it's an experience that's hard to
describe my name is Jim Campbell Spitler
and I'm a forest canopy ecologist and a
wildlife biologist and I'm pretty sure I
have the best job in the world my job is
to climb into the eagle's nest and
capture and work with chicks yeah he's a
monster and the reason why we're doing
this is we're trying to get blood
samples and we can use those blood
samples to look at environmental
contaminants and how they get into the
bald eagles food source and make me
chase you huh don't you come off there
come down it's a challenging species to
work with it's got a really sharp hooked
beak and its talons are big and powerful
and you don't want to let them grab
ahold of you because they can really do
some damage all right let's go down this
is a wild animal so you never know what
can happen the Channel Islands are an
island chain off the coast of Southern
California do you think I've no luck few
off they're a desert island system you
get out there and you can stand on top
of these Bluffs and you can see the
Pacific a whole 360 degree view of just
the most beautiful ocean you can ever
imagine
you've got not only bald eagles you have
peregrine falcons that are nesting on
the sea cliffs just tell me if she's
coming in you've got a host of different
seabirds and it's just a magical place a
research it may look invasive but really
what a marked primary concerns is the
safety of these young birds that were
handling so we go to great lengths to
ensure that we don't injure them and
that when we put them back in the nest
they're just as well off as when we
first encountered them like you the bald
eagles are national birds so it's quite
an honor for me to get to work with this
species quite often I'll just sit in
that nest for a moment and just take in
the view and just think wow you know
it's just an honor to get up there be
able to share that view and that
experience with them just for that
moment in time
[Music]
this is ver money a martial Eagle the
largest African Eagle they have enough
power in one foot to break a human arm
as powerful as they are their strength
in numbers continues to decrease in the
wild martial eagles weigh in at around
14 pounds with a wingspan up to eight
and a half feet bomani is native to
sub-saharan Africa preferring open woods
wooded savanna and thorn bush habitats
he is an apex predator sitting at the
top of the avian food chain
unfortunately they are being persecuted
by humans mistakenly believed to be a
predatory threat to livestock in reality
domestic animals make up a very small
percentage of their diet add to that a
shrinking habitat which reduces prey the
martial eagle population is dwindling
fast this is the martial eagle
this is the northern bald eagle an
iconic bird that we almost lost for good
only a few decades ago northern Bald
Eagles are the larger of the two
subspecies of the bald eagle their
wingspan can reach over seven feet they
are powerful fliers that soar through
the air reaching over 40 miles per hour
when gliding they're excellent predators
attacking from above with their long and
sharp talons
by the 1960s their population was
decimated with less than 1000 left in
the wild chemicals from pesticides
traveled up the food chain rendering
these top predators sterile or unable to
lay healthy eggs thankfully after
massive regulations were put in place
they have made a near full recovery
today loss of suitable habitat
if Dilla threat as they are very
sensitive to human activity this is the
northern bald eagle
[Music]
if you go into the water we see a great
white shark what's your reaction you're
not gonna think twice you're home and
asked to get out of there
Falcons are the great white shark of the
sky and birds are terrified of them my
name is Mark Adam I am the president of
Falcon environmental services our
company uses the world's oldest sport
falconry to protect planes in flight
birds can be really dangerous to
airplanes if a golf strikes an engine it
can potentially stop it in which case
the aircraft can come out of the sky
there are multiple methods that airports
can use to control birds
sirens another very common one is
pyrotechnics birds are not dumb they get
used to that stuff but one thing that
they can never get used to is the
instinctive fear of a falcon
here we raise Falcons and when they
hatch out we rear them for three or four
days and put them back with the parents
[Music]
the skills that we use to train our
Raptors date back to 3000 BC when
falconry was first introduced utilizing
hoods Jess's and conditioning methods
the birds are trained for about 30 to 60
days where then they go out to our
Airport operations
on a given day they are requested
numerous times by the control tower to
intervene at specific spots on the
airfield at which time the Falcon is
deployed and it is allowed to fly around
the airport until the birds have been
dispersed when the falconer wants the
Falcon to come back all he has to do is
take out the lure which has a piece of
food on it swing it around his head and
they found can will come in in order to
be fed I enjoy bird-watching but I find
falconry almost like the chance to see
something that happens every day in the
wild but I get a chance to see it up
close every day
[Music]
eagle feathers give us that strength and
courage to go on
they've been in our ceremonies for
centuries and to be able to have these
feathers in our time of prayer and our
time I need is really important to us
we're at the National Eagle repository
last riru received right at 2700 Eagles
that were found dead or died for one
reason or another and we provide goose
feathers from eagles to Native Americans
for their religious and cultural
purposes they are protected by various
laws such as the bald and golden eagle
Protection Act so people can't just go
picking them up but this this way it
allows Native Americans a lawful way to
obtain and possess Eagles the birds that
we get have died from various causes
they often collide with something it
causes them to break a wing and of
course results in death but usually
those injuries are pretty minor to the
feathers so we we could still use most
of the feathers so we're checking what
needs to be replaced there or what
feathers need to be added in in an
effort to try to give them the
equivalent of one whole bird
[Music]
the role of the National repository it's
very important it helps us to keep going
with our lives that we know it
it's good to know that you're part of
something that means so much to a group
of people and that you're playing a role
in protecting a very treasured resource
[Music]